il a la réputation d'être l'un des plus
doués de sa génération dj mehdi propose
un album solo qui mélange beaucoup
d'influencé de musique rap nouvelle
génération par quelqu'un qui admire
beaucoup les beatles rencontre signée
dominique poncet et jérémie drieu à le
voir arriver tout seul tranquillement à
son studio de répétition on ne dirait
jamais qu'il est l'un des dj les plus
courtisés du monde sait que mehdi 25 ans
est un être paradoxal c'est un enfant de
la banlieue nord de paris mais il
s'exprime comme un intello du 16e il est
classé dans la catégorie rappeur mais il
se défend dans les trains il compose en
empruntant à toutes les musiques
mais il réussit à créer des sons
singulier c'est pour tout ça
qu'aujourd'hui médiers devenu star
quand j'ai commencé je pensais pas du
tout à ça en fait j'étais vraiment trop
jeune je me rendais pas bien compte de
même des attributs comme ça à culturels
ou sociaux du rap et du mouvement hip
hop en général je me rendais pas bien
compte c'était surtout environnementale
pour moi c'était lui dit que c'est
écrire sur les murs faire du bruit que
la bouche scratch est comme ça dansait
et ensuite j'ai cherché à ce que ce soit
peut-être un peu peut-être un peu plus
singuliers ou le fait qu'elle puisse les
choses qui viennent de plein droit les
amener dans une petite boîte secoué
comme ça et ensuite en faire ce qu'on
propose son propre mélange et puis nos
frères comme ça aux gens c'est ça super
intéressantes comme des couleurs et puis
après je tableau la musique c'est super
league quoi je ne vois pas de limite à
sac la mort d'amy il envoie d'autant
moins qu'en fait son truc c'est de
marier tous les genres ou de les
fracasser jusqu'à leur donner une
couleur typiquement médias un truc
important pour moi quand j'ai eu l'idée
interprète en particulier des gens qu'on
a une grosse personnalité sur le sur les
chansons comme needham comme karim très
après de m'approprier la chanson pour
dire que c'est ma chanson est pas celle
des gens qui va être précieuse
généticien là c'est pas pour moi si
c'est insuffisant pour toi la mère qui
prive en effet signé d'abord quand on
parle de rêve ce jeu j'essaie de pas
être égoïste mais je pense surtout au
bien-être de ma famille et à ma mère
mais je sais pas j'ai envie de faire
nous disent d'abord j'ai envie d'un joli
de faire le disque en fait horreur
en attendant ce disque majuscule serait
inventeur de son vient de sortir son
premier album solo à juste titre il est
encensé